I'D REALLY LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MAN WHO MADE THIS SHOW HAPPEN,
JON STEWART.
>> TOMORROW JON WILL HOST HIS
FINAL DAILY SHOW AND I WANT TO
SALUTE HIM FOR A TRULY
REMARKABLE RUN.
I MEAN HE DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING
LINED UP AT THE MOMENT BUT JON'S
BROTHER-IN-LAW MANAGES A
BENNIGAN'S BACK IN JERSEY, I AM
JUST SAYING.
HE SAYS THEY MAY HAVE SOME
OPENINGS AT THE END OF AUGUST
WHEN KIDS GO BACK TO COLLEGE SO
MAYBE THAT WILL TURN INTO
SOMETHING.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT AS A VIEWER, I AM GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THE LAUGHS AND SANITY HE
HAS PROVIDED OVER THE YEARS.
AND AS A PERFORMER I AM GRATEFUL
THAT HE HAD THE CONFIDENCE TO
ENTRUST ME WITH THIS SHOW.
AND AS A CITIZEN, I AM REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR ALL HE'S DONE
HELPING GET HEALTHCARE TO OUR
VETERANS AND 9/11 FIRST
RESPONDERS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ] THANK
YOU, JON.
WE ARE GOING TO MISS YOU, BUDDY
WE REALLY ARE GOING TO MISS YOU,
AND JON, IF YOU EVER WANT TO
COME TO A TAPING, YOU KNOW, AND
HANG OUT, RIGHT?  JUST VISIT THE
NIGHTLYSHOW.COM/TICKETS.
AND I GUARANTEE THEY WILL HOOK
YOU UP, JON.